bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono a pari j
oggi siamo su ice un indie horror un
ennesimo indie horror di cui non so
assolutamente nulla che mi avete
consigliato uscito da poco in tanti in
basso a destra c'è un coso non mi
cornaca cui si chiamano strada ma temo
che prova scannerizzarlo ok
che cosa mi significa sta roba deve
essere un hotel un villaggio vacanze
pubblicità così comunque non importa
dato che non ha la più pallida idea di
che cosa si tratta andiamo subito a
giocarlo perché non lo so giovane talk
about this breaking business
ora dice che dentro iab uk all gatland
20 becks aiab front door che ok plessen
ictus
hanno sbagliato ok va beh
tanto erano consigli niente di che
andiamo andiamo anche senza ok ragazzi
amo partiti c'è un letto che secondo me
potrebbe essere tranquillamente letto di
uno dei sette nani perché non so come
una persona possa dormire su sta roba
va beh allora raga un gatto è
intrappolato del televisore o questa non
me la spiego non me la spiego non me la
spiego calmi calmi calmi che cazzo
succede io me ne vado a me ne vado
uno su venti uno su venti cosa ho aperto
semplicemente il comodino va bene io me
ne vado ribatte il gatto si tira fuori
da solo [ __ ] eh vabbè un
termosifone cos'è questo 2 su 20 o che
queste le devo raccogliere
beh dai raga siamo già due è già buono
ok press e mezzo si sa mai
raga un po più di luce mi sembrava di
essere in paradiso comunque ci siamo st
portano devo aprire adesso ci sono
dovrebbero esserci tipo delle scale
buongiorno mi sa dire dove devo andare
perché madonna raga ma quanto è buio c'è
vabbè dettagli con che c'è un'altra
porta che è nato livietta inetto find 18
becks moro che questa ragazza è uscita
ricordiamoci devo andare di cori
quant'altro va del tutto buio quindi
diamo di qua si è l'ambientazione
parecchio spaventosa che eran cos'è
che cazzo è questa ok dieci anni di
sfiga sono passato sotto la scala non so
neanche dove sto andando merda
forse era quello ma come mai ci sono
gatti ovunque anche del tosto vaso
comunque non so che cosa ho visto non mi
interessa
c'è non ho capito neanche bene che
cos'era però c'era scritto di correre io
ho corso senza neanche capire che cosa
stava succedendo
provo a tornare indietro piano molto
molto piano
salve mi prendo altri dieci anni di
sfiga se passo qui sotto ma devo capire
cos'era c'è nessuno
oh cazzo c'è il nuovo ma cos'è via via
via via via via via fritti ok ok io ho
una scopa io ho una scopa merda merda
ok mi ha preso cos'era quella roba
va bene è allora calmiamoci un secondo
sembrano lo so una donna in polvere in
poche parole che mi segue e non ho
capito perché una cosa è certa la scopa
non la intimidisce
vabbè cerchiamo di tornare dove eravamo
prima ok
piano piano salve se vedete passare
qualcosa
fatemelo sapere prima sento sento uno
spiffero probabilmente quando senti lo
spiffero è meglio che te la dà a gambe
run
ok che aspetto ho capito già tutto è la
stoffa la scopa non serve da scopo lo sa
ok ok un altro gatto nel forno
ok piano forse qui dentro non entra dato
che qui dentro siamo abbastanza sicuro
se riesco mi faccio un panino ok non
posso allora un gatto arrosto non è male
comunque
no va bene allora faccio a meno anche di
quello allora è pieno di pattumiera non
si però se ti devi lamentare fallo in
silenzio che qui sto contemplando
l'immondizia
niente di tra fare a meno che io non mi
suicidi buttandomi giù dalla finestra
devo uscire
oppure c'è anche la presa della corrente
ma che cazzo sto dicendo usciamo messo
ok se n'è appena andata ragazzi se n'è
appena andata quindi non tremano prima
pi day 1a qui dentro che devo prendere
la roba dell'altra volta allora il gatto
nel maso penso che ci sia sempre ok
ragazzo paura ad uscire però devo farlo
per forza perché se no posso rimanere
qui dentro col gatto tutta la vita
allora sembra che non ci sia nessuno
credo salve perfetto entriamo ok siamo
in una nuova stanza laga non so che cosa
c'è guide e un pianoforte ok allora io
ok allora presumo che io debba tornare
indietro ma suonerei volentieri qualcosa
pur di non tornare indietro
vabbè come faccio a girare però la tipa
ma che cazzo è bene lago ha capito che
non posso stare nemmeno vicino alle
porte
vado vado vado vado vado avanti avanti
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti avanti indietro indietro indietro
indietro indietro indietro ok ok ok ok
calmi calmi
ok vado ad ok ragazzi provo ma si può
anche andare 18 non mi ricordavo ok
allora andiamo di sotto perché la tipa
penso sia di sopra
cos'è sta roba
non lo voglio neanche sapere andiamo
avanti ci sono ragano so dove siamo ma
c'è roba che lampeggiano in fondo ok
andiamo di qua è veramente sembra di
essere nei sotterranei quelli di
svendere woods ma noi andiamo avanti lo
stesso ci sono dei tubi e l'ho presa qui
si prefetto non so dove sto andando raga
cos'è un lancio di scarpe sta roba
siamo a 9 su 10 su 20 sono andro
velocissimo beh perché qui sotto non
passa nessuno zio quante sono
madonna era davanti sono come cazzo sia
presso a fare ok ok era una porta
normalissima bene ok ragazzi amo a 14
non vedo nessuno ok ci siamo beh quindi
raga sto finendo
questo è peggio di ieri quelli in di
nuovo giocato che andava velocissimo che
cazzo sono sti cosi ma questo è
veramente un topo siamo sicuri che non
siano i gatti oh cazzo
ok non è un gatto non è un gatto non è
una merda merda nono sono 16 non posso
morire ha detto ok di sopra di sopra di
sopra di gioco veloce veloce buongiorno
ne vado di fretta mi scusi veloce veloce
veloce
ok non so dove sta andando la gamma me
ne mancano 4 ok
apriti o per dire no a preti porta di
merda ok mi sto più andando nei corridoi
a caso
corridoi a caso nel corridoio a caso ok
ce ne sono altre due siamo 18 merda non
sa neanche dove sto andando perfetto 3
ce l'ha fatta ragazzi ce lo fa 21 21 ok
ok ragazzi siamo siamo a 21 devo
soltanto riuscire a tornare indietro
tra l'altro volevo farvi notare che sta
roba era la stessa cosa che mi è apparsa
quando scannerizzato il codice
all'inizio del gioco bene allora dov'è
la porta si apre no evidentemente no la
candela si può spegnere e accendere non
ci vedo l'utilità buongiorno che cazzo
era sta roba
che cosa mi che è successo ma si vede
che puoi vedere dove la tipa a ok e ne è
allora nel corridoio quali fianco
perfetto allora forse proprio questo
significato del gioco ice accelera
c'erano anche prima si cosi ma non li ho
pagati di striscio e vabbè a sto punto
noi usciamo perché non so proprio dove
andare ok
buongiorno sono di fretta mi scusi c'è
una scala però non devo andare di qua
devo tornare indietro se mi metto a
leggere la divina commedia no grazie
devo riuscire a tornare indietro
calmiamoci un secondo
allora siamo finiti qui devo riuscire a
capire dove la tipa per non farmi
sorprendere
ok praticamente devo tornare all'inizio
fin qui ci siamo
l'unico problema è che per arrivare qui
ho corso in mezzo miliardo di corridoi
non capendone anche dove stavo andando
infatti non ho la più pallida idea di
dove sono finito però c'è la mappa
giustamente madonna
ok giustamente siamo al piano di sopra e
quindi un casino
vabbè lasciamo stare la mappa vediamo di
uscire con calma però ok perfetto non
esco più indietro cristo attraverso
attraverso la porta attraverso la porta
madonna
ok [ __ ] adesso ve lo faccio tutto
spedito me ne frega niente se
ammazzatevi tutti quanti non mi
avvertite mai stronzi ok
almeno abbiamo capito una cosa ragazzi
abbiamo capito che
gli occhi sul muro ovvero questi servono
a capire dove cazzo sta narrativa e in
questo momento sta qui ok ok bene sono
utili sti cosi meno male si può uscire
perfetto anno quando ci sono ancora
stato non ci sono anche stato neanche
nella porta di fianco veramente però
vabbè c'è qualcosa qui si fa la via
visto una cosa luccicano ok allora con
canna con canna un paio di palle adesso
me la faccio tutta spedita che si
portano tutti dovrei riuscire ad
arrivare al piano di sotto
prendere velocemente tanto si può
prendere se ne possono prendere più di
20 e poi tornare qui
perché praticamente non è che devi
prendere per forza ventina di riprendere
almeno 20
in teoria sì ci dovrei arrivare
abbastanza velocemente questi non sono
topi comunque che cazzo
a maggio napoli c'era una porta qui casa
vista prima ok dove lucia siamo finiti
bene c'è un vediamo dove al piano di
sopra perfetto allora smettila
riguardarlo ok corrie se allora raga
piano di sopra posso muovermi abbastanza
liberamente perché arriverà di sotto
prima possibile di sicuro perfetto qua
ce ne sono sempre un casino di cos'è un
po bisogno della chiave per entrare oa
tt tanto l'ho preso attraverso le sbarre
perché c'è un braccio che mister
fantastic mi fa una pippa comunque
torniamo indietro ho accettato e pieno
di sacchetti e c'è un gatto dentro
ok non so come può essere lì dentro
questo non me lo so spiegare
corri corri ok ok ok ok bene ce
l'abbiamo dietro ancora penso di sì
dobbiamo cosa no ok non corri maledetto
stronzo markwins lander vai così lento
cazzo di idiota che mai dai cazzo ma
perché
ma perché ma perché nei videogiochi
horror io devo comandare gli obesi
perché
ok ok ok time out proteggimi to
maledetto gatto nel fuoco
si paga mi sto perdendo
devo riuscire ok 18 devo riuscire a
trovare la porta di prima perché quella
sta per scendere me lo sento
dov'è la paz dove cazzo e la porta di
prima c'è ma possibile siamo sempre qui
sotto ah ok ci sia perfetto ok calmi
calmi
vediamo dove al piano di perfetta piano
di sopra e devo dovrei aspettare chissà
quante ne ho di 15 cosi perfetto non ne
ho più a sto punto direi di andare di
sopra però di sopra c'è lei quindi non è
proprio il massimo
ok allora facciamo così io provo a
salire se per caso la vedo gli inizi a
scappare darmela grande è ok quante me
ne ma cazzo gatto nell'orologio ok ok ok
calmi kf lo [ __ ] di brutto
va bene allora aspettiamo tre secondi
poi provate utilizzarlo così almeno
veduto beh speriamo che vada lì sotto
poi mi son trovati sotto riscatto adesso
no no è andata di sopra sta [ __ ] ok
raga non ha senso tutto ciò non ha senso
non posso c'era perché quando sono 18
[ __ ]
e quando niente va bene
allora io non so neanche dove è andata
precisamente misto dove cazzo sono
finito prima non ero neanche arrivato
qui
va beh noi c'è un successo allora non
vorrei trovarci come in which una testa
però io ho uno sturalavandini non mi fa
incazzare che sono violento quell'isola
lavandini
mi è rimasto per caso un costo per
vedere dove no perfetto allora andiamo a
culo non c'è l'affetto me ne manca una
di gatti nel computer
ok ragazzo cestino epico sembra una
faccina e vabbè comunque siamo arrivati
a 21 c'è una stampante i gatti nei
documenti che perché c'è una stampa ma
che perfetto sempre di sopra è qui
dietro tra l'altro che è perfetto
sono riuscito ad attivare al momento
giusto ok raga devo riuscire a tornare
di sotto ok dovrebbe non esserci più
perché è passata appena adesso perfetto
a meno che non è andata di là cosa c'è
di qua ma di qua si torna indietro mi
con orrore sono arrivato ragazzi dove
cazzo se ho trovato una chiave ho
trovato una chiave a caso completamente
a caso siamo nei corridoi bene siamo nei
corridoi
devo tornare no no no
mi incazzo mi incazzo se muoio m'incazzo
se muoiono di qua no di qua no sto
tornando in vietnam sto tornando
indietro
raga aiuto sono di mode ovvero prima e
non ho più corsa se mi spunta adesso
sono morto se mi spunta intra stronzo di
merda se ok 24 sto prendendo sacchetti
che non mi servono dove dove cazzo
andato che sta andando di sotto perfetto
devo riuscire ad andarmene di qua subito
sera gao kay ragazzi siamo devo trovare
solo le scale devo soltanto trovare
quelle fottute scale di merda devo
trovare no non è di qua perfetto è di
qua che cazzo è una cassa sto trovando
di tutto meno che il punto da dove sono
arrivata una vi rendete conto cioè non
ha senso una lavagna ma che cazzo ti
posso è questo fatemi capire mi muovo
nel bar
ok basta raga
mi sto perde non riesco a tornare
indietro ma vi rendete conto allora dove
siamo mamma mia che luce allora il bagno
e questo le scale sono a quando esco dal
bagno la porta a destra allora deve
uscire dal bagno che è questo ok appena
esco devo andare a destra e poi di nuovo
a destra ok se ho capito qualcosa di
quello che ho letto devo pregare che non
ci sia perché non ho più la mappa ma che
kakà [ __ ] porti una fontana porca
pazza con la [ __ ] di merda stressa di
minchia che se ti prende un occhiata
fico due carrozze i [ __ ] puritana
che non sei altro che lo stura lavandini
tano il filo superi ok ragazzi sono
siamo di nuovo a 20 e siamo di nuovo
dov'eravamo prima adesso vedo dove vedo
dove è 18 e 18 st brutta stronza ok devo
riuscire è perfetto ma tornare
ok perfetto sono anch'io un genio del
caso però perché se vedo che di sotto
che cosa minchia vado bene allora dove
sta andando adesso
ok ok devo darmi la mossa però se mi do
una mossa ce la faccio dai dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
se se se ho vinto ho vinto brutta
stronzo vinto mi sono talmente incazzato
che devo bere 12 litri di camomilla
quindi non scrivo niente
vabbè raga direi di chiudere qui
comunque a parte tutto come videogame
horror non è male anzi vabbè c'è sempre
con la storia di raccogliere della roba
però comunque come ambientazione è come
scopo in generale è abbastanza carino
quindi vi consiglio di scaricare lo
trovate in descrizione provateci anche
voi e mantenete la calma io vi consiglio
una flebo di camomilla proprio attaccata
mentre giocate perché
diciamo può aiutare comunque come al
solito se il video è piaciuto lasciate
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo un
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]